moving on to other news now and
lebanon's caretaker prime minister has
warned the Palestinian president that
the Lebanese Army will intervene if
rival factions don't stop fighting in
the inel hallway refugee camp najib
McCarthy says the gun battles are a
flagrant violation of Lebanese
sovereignty five days of battles between
rival Palestinian groups have killed at
least 13 people and displaced thousands
let's bring in our correspondent Zain of
whether she is joining us live from the
inside the refugee camp in southern
Lebanon so what's the latest there zaina
is that very fragile lolin fighting
holding
yes an uneasy calm but a very tense
situation because people are still
concerned that clashes could resume at
any time there is no formal agreement in
place no ceasefire no agreement to end
the fighting and that is why hundreds of
families are still displaced inside
mosques and schools waiting for security
guarantees in order to be able to go
home it's been nearly a week since the
latest bout of violence began this is a
camp which has seen violence time and
time again between the Rival Palestinian
factions and we spoke to a top commander
in the fatah movement this is the
mainstream movement the strongest party
inside the camp their top Commander was
killed on Sunday and they've been
demanding The Killers be brought to
Justice the other groups like junda Shem
have still not heeded that demand but
fatah is also telling us that a military
option or a showdown is currently not on
the table because this is a costly
option so right now we are at a standoff
of military stalemate and the question
is how long can this continue markets
are closed in the camp and people are
poor if they do not work they were
unable to put food on the table
all right in Xena so no formal ceasefire
agreement and also a very unusual
security agreement because the refugee
camp is in Lebanon but Lebanese forces
are not in charge of security there
yes Lebanese the Lebanese state has no
jurisdiction inside Palestinian camps
the Rival factions they're in charge of
security it's a long-standing agreement
dating back decades we heard the
caretaker prime minister energy tell the
Palestinian president Mahmoud Abbas that
the Army May intervene to contain the
fighting but that's easier said than
done it is not a decision that miati
takes alone you're going to need a
consensus among all the top politicians
in this country it would be a costly
operation the last time the Army did get
involved in one Palestinian Camp it was
because it was a Target it was targeted
and this time around the warring parties
have not targeted the army so very few
options really on the table or at least
the option of a military Showdown would
be very very costly Jean deshan and the
other armed groups refusing to hand over
the killers so it's not clear how long
this situation can continue zaina thank
you very much for that that is our
correspondence live from inside the iron
and Holloway refugee camp